-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show"!
You're here. You made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
This is very exciting.
The 46th President of
the United States, Joe Biden,
is my guest tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
You know you have a crazy job
when you're meeting
with Vladimir Putin and me
in the same week, you know?
That's right -- President Biden
is here to discuss
the economy,
his infrastructure bill,
and break down the first two
episodes of
the "Sex and the City" reboot.
What happened to Samantha?
The president was
actually supposed to be here
earlier this week,
but he had to lay low after
he lit the Fox News
Christmas tree on fire.
And...
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Before the show,
I asked President Biden
how excited he is to be
with us on a scale of 1-10.
And he said, "10,
but 6 without inflation."
I thought it was...
Biden's got a busy day.
Besides talking to us,
he's also talking to
the National Guard
to prep for SantaCon.
Here's some good news.
I saw that jobless claims
have dropped to
the lowest level in 52 years.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Is that how you wanted me
to say it, Mr. President?
That's right --
everyone's working.
In fact,
for the first time ever,
contestants on "The Bachelor"
don't have to make up
a fake job.
"I'm a personal trainer,
entrepreneur,
social-media coach."
Well, here in
New York City tomorrow,
thousands of people will pack
the streets for SantaCon.
Or, as the NYPD calls it,
"The Nightmare
Before Christmas."
That's right --
starting tomorrow at 10:00 a.m.,
bartenders will be handing out
more shots than
a CVS pharmacist.
That's right -- SantaCon is
officially back
in New York City.
It was canceled last year,
but this weekend,
thousands of people
dressed like Santa
are expected to take part in
a citywide bar crawl.
So I thought I'd welcome the
tradition back with a tiny song.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
♪♪
♪ Christmas in New York
is for you, and it's for me ♪
♪ And a couple of thousand
drunken Santas
stumbling down the street ♪
♪ With pillows
stuffed under red shirts,
the most I ever saw ♪
♪ Fake white beards
and Christmas cheer
and cases of White Claw ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
♪ But they don't got
no reindeer ♪
♪ No cocoa piping hot ♪
♪ Just snowstorms
of Axe Body Spray ♪
♪ And dollar Jell-O shots ♪
♪ There's Santas on the subway ♪
♪ There's Santas taking naps ♪
♪ One Santa is break-dancing ♪
♪ One's barfing in his hat ♪
♪ Some are singing carols ♪
♪ Some say "ho, ho, ho" ♪
♪ But most of them
are running, shouting,
"Look out, bro! Po-po!"
♪ One drunk Santa,
two drunk Santa ♪
♪ Three drunk Santa, four ♪
♪ I saw Santa kiss Green M&M
at the M&M store ♪
♪ So get your booster,
wear a mask,
be safe this SantaCon ♪
♪ 'Cause beer and milk
and cookies
don't protect from Omicron ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you.
Thank you, Roots.
Some entertainment news.
Steven Spielberg's
"West Side Story"
hit theaters today.
Yeah. Some people said,
if they want to watch
a heartbreaking story
about the Jets,
they should just watch football.
[ Cymbal crash ]
Well, this is fun.
Margaritaville just announced
its own cruise line
that will start sailing
out of Florida in the spring.
A Margaritaville cruise
out of Florida.
What could possibly go right?
But it sounds pretty cool.
They even line the hot-tub rims
with margarita salt.
And, finally,
the state of Delaware
is replacing a highway exit sign
after they realized
the original one had
a small typo in "Delaware."
They left out one of the A's.
Take a look at this.
Delware Avenue, yeah.
Let's see the sign again
after they added the "A."
Delwarea Avenue.
There you go.
When he saw that,
President Biden
grabbed the ladder and said,
"I'll fix it myself."
We have a great show.
Guys, we have
exactly six shows left before
we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time for
that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for "12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters."
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ 12 Days of
Christmas Sweaters ♪
♪ Six days left ♪
-That is right.
Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a stunning
Christmas sweater from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
Now, since there are
six shows left,
let's open door number 6.
[ Drumroll ]
Whenever you're ready.
Alright.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't understand.
I don't quite -- Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow!
Oh, and it -- Turn it.
So, it comes
with a hat on the back.
-Whoo!
-You can't wear it.
You can't wear it.
It's stuck to the sweater.
-Mm-hmm.
-Interesting. That's an
interesting way to do it.
Now let's see who's going to go
home with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Quest,
can I get a drumroll, please?
Who wants this great sweater?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on down!
Yes, come over here.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Welcome!
Thank you so much
for being here.
This is it.
What is your name?
-Tori.
-Tori, where are you from?
-I'm from Boston.
-From Boston! We love Boston!
[ Cheers and applause ]
It does get
a little chilly in Boston,
so this will go perfect.
Are you a cow-- Do you like
country and being a cowboy?
-I guess I do now.
-Yes, of course.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, it's yours now.
Would you like to try it on?
We'd love to, yeah.
I think there might be
one more button.
-Yeah, one more button.
-I think this is
going to be great.
You can't wear the hat.
No, the hat is just decoration.
You don't wear the hat.
Oh, whoa, whoa. This is subtle.
Are you kidding me?
Are you joking?
That is phenomenal.
Look at that!
Look at that hat on the back.
That's unbelievable.
It looks gorgeous.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Congratulations.
Give her a
round of applause, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]